[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the ai
alignment podcast i'm lucas perry today
we have a conversation with peter
railton that explores
meta ethics moral epistemology moral
learning
and how these areas of philosophy may or
may not inform
ai alignment the core problem that this
episode explores
is that as systems become more and more
autonomous
and increasingly participate in social
roles that require
social functioning it will become
increasingly necessary for
ai systems to be familiar with and
sensitive to
morally salient features of the world
this requires that systems have the
capacity
for moral learning and developing an
understanding of human
normative processes and beliefs on top
of that
structuring any kind of procedure for
moral learning in ai systems will bring
in meta-ethical beliefs and assumptions
that would be wise to understand and be
explicit about
for a little more context some key
motivating questions for this episode to
consider are when and what is the degree
to which
ai systems will require the capacity for
moral learning
how might metaethics inform or not
inform ai alignment
and how do you structure a system such
that it can engage in moral learning in
a way that would be
broadly endorsed and would satisfy other
ethical
or meta-ethical principles that we care
about
for some more background i did a podcast
with peter singer on his transition from
being
a moral anti-realist to a moral realist
that episode is titled on becoming a
moral realist
with peter singer in that episode we
explore his meta-ethical views
and peter singer mentions conversations
and debate between derek parfit
and peter railton on issues in meta
ethics
so the second half of this podcast is
dedicated to understanding and unpacking
peter railton's meta ethics
and how it compares with peter singers
and derek parfit's views
this podcast is pretty philosophy heavy
so if you're into that and the ethics of
ai
then you'll appreciate this episode you
can subscribe to and follow this podcast
on your preferred podcasting platform
by searching for future of life peter
railton
is a professor of philosophy at the
university of michigan ann arbor
he has a phd from princeton and
primarily researches ethics and the
philosophy of science
he focuses especially on questions about
the nature of
objectivity value norms and explanation
recently he has also begun working in
aesthetics
moral psychology and the theory of
action
and with that let's get into our
conversation with peter railton
just to start off here sometimes i've
heard that meta ethics doesn't matter or
one might wonder
when does meta ethics ever matter in
real life anyway i'm curious you have
any thoughts on
whether meta ethics matters at all for
ai alignment
well in the most general sense
metaethics concerns questions about the
nature of morality
its foundation the possibility of moral
knowledge
how we might acquire it the meanings of
moral claims
how they stand in relation to our other
forms of knowledge
and so it does seem to me as if med
ethics is important
in thinking about the problems of ethics
in a.i
partly because i think a lot of people
have in the back of their minds
skeptical concerns about morality and
therefore
doubt whether there could be objective
value they think perhaps value is
entirely subjective
and if that's your approach then you
might say the
challenge of creating ethical ai is not
a very well-defined problem
what would be the subjective attitude of
a properly
aligned ai system you might consult the
population and find out what the
average point of view is but we know the
average point of view right now
is very different from what it was 200
or 300 years ago
we think in some ways it's improved
since then
and we think in some ways where we are
now could be improved
so we can't reduce the question of
ethics and ai to something like
opinion sampling and that's because
morality has
objective dimensions and we use these to
criticize our preferences
and our opinions and so any decent
ethics for ai
would build into the concept the
possibility of correction and criticism
and for that you need some thought of
what would constitute correction or
criticism how would we justify moral
claims
and that takes us to the heart of med
ethics right and
there's a lot of moral anti-realists or
people who think that morality is
subjective
in i guess hard sciences and computer
science in general so
this also applies to the alignment
community
if one feels that moral claims or moral
attitudes
are subjective then this choice that you
mentioned to
take the average of general popular
opinion is itself a moral choice
which is the expression of one own's
subjective
moral attitude from that point of view
and within a
subjective framework there's no way to
resolve that except take the expression
of all the power dynamics
of everyone's subjective moral attitudes
and see what comes out of that right
well yeah that would be one of the
problems the project
of creating ethical ai or ai alignment
as it's sometimes called can't be the
problem of giving
our value system to machines because
there is no
unique value system that we possess it
could be
the project of trying to make it
possible for the machine to learn
the most justified value system and
part of the problem i think is that
people have exaggerated notions of what
it would take
to justify moral claims they assume for
example that there's a
huge gulf between facts and values that
there are
no reasonable ways of bridging that gulf
and
that in general what it would take to
have objective morality would look
something like
the universe with what god would do only
without god
one of the problems with that thought is
that that's a model of morality is a
set of commands given by some kind of a
divine enforcer
and if you think that absent's such a
divine enforcer
morality could only be subjective then i
think you're missing the idea of what
morality
really does the existence of a divine
enforcer
wouldn't bring morality into existence a
divine enforcer could be either good
or malevolent and so understanding what
it is to do moral criticism
should be an integral part of the
challenge of thinking about
ethics in ai but looking at moral
criticism we have many practices of
moral criticism
and those aren't strictly speaking
subjective and we
value them because they help correct our
subjective opinions
so i think there's two parts of meta
ethics that i would
like to see if you have any thoughts on
how they
may or may not apply here meta-ethical
epistemology like
how is it that you know things about
meta ethics and
whatever may be metaphysically true
about
ethics or not so you brought up
religion there so in terms of i guess
what would be called
divine command theory morality would
have a
metaphysically very solid ground as
being codified
by god or something like that actually
i'd say
that that wouldn't give us a solid
metaphysical ground
the fact that commands come from a being
that's supremely powerful
and even one that's supremely knowing
would not make those commands
moral commands those conditions are
perfectly compatible
with amoral values what we would need is
a perfectly knowledgeable
entirely powerful and all good god
so-called triple-a god that means the
concept of good is independent of the
concept of
god itself and understanding what it
would be
for the commands of a divine super
powerful being to be good
just takes us right back to the question
of the nature of morality we don't
solve it by introducing supreme beings
right right so i'm not trying to
justify or lay out the divine command
theory only using it to i guess
attempt to explain how epistemology and
metaphysics fit into meta ethics
to me it seems like what is relevant
here to ai alignment is
that how one believes one can
know things about meta ethics and
whether or not there can be
agreement upon meta-ethical epistemology
would be the foundation upon which
meta-ethical moral learning in machine
systems
could be expressed there is sort of a
meta
view on the epistemology of metaethics
where one could say
because there are no moral facts the
epistemology is
whatever human beings are doing to think
about moral thought
and there isn't a correct epistemology
whereas one
could whether through naturalism in your
meta ethics or through non-naturalism in
peter singer's ethics believe they're to
be moral truths and that thus there is
a correct epistemology about metaethics
and that that epistemology of metaethics
could be used
to instantiate meta-ethical learning
in machine systems so one
thought would be there is one true
morality and
we're capable of knowing it that itself
wouldn't get us very far
in epistemology until we could say what
those methods of knowing are
an approach that's got something like
that as an assumption
but that doesn't assume that we know
where the destination is ultimately
going to be
would be to ask do we have good
practices of moral criticism
and do those help us to solve actual
problems social problems interpersonal
problems problems of their own lives
and then to look at the ways in which we
use morality in these contexts to
solve problems and that brings it down
to the level
that it's something that comes within
the scope of what can be learned
and if we look at children's learning we
see that their
development as moral creatures proceeds
in pace with their
understanding of causality their
understanding of
theory of mind their capacity to form
counterfactual thoughts because it's
really an integrated body
of general understanding and so for
example
the idea of solutions that are positive
sums
of game theoretic challenges that's
something that can be agreed upon by all
parties
to be a desirable thing and so looking
at strategies that have the possibility
of
yielding positive sums cooperative
strategies
strategies of trustworthiness of
signaling
strategies which enable us to coordinate
with each other
understand each other's intentions those
have a justification that we can give
in terms that are not tied to any one
particular person's interests
which address interests generally and
which we can defend in
an impartial way and so that would be an
example of
a way in which we could say those are
more reasonable solutions more justified
solutions
there's an analogy here with the
epistemology generally
if someone were to come to me and say
well you claim to have knowledge
how do you demonstrate that how would
you show that your understanding of
knowledge is genuine knowledge
i'd have to say well sorry i can't
demonstrate that any demonstration would
presuppose knowledge and so i can't pull
it out of a hat
and i can't derive it from nothing so
what can i do i can say well
here are our practices of epistemic
criticism and while we have
disagreements in various places about
what counts as evidence or what does not
do those practices deliver the kinds of
results that we would expect
from reasonable epistemologies making
possible things like scientific inquiry
and technology
and so on and we could say well that's
what epistemology
could be expected to give us we do have
methods that can improve
our ability to solve such problems in
just those ways
we can find various ways to justify them
in terms of
probabilities looking for ways in which
we can increase accuracy and estimations
and so those are different ways in which
by looking at our actual practices
of epistemic criticism we try to get
some traction
on the problem of knowledge and i would
argue we should do the same thing
about morality if we start from the
standpoint of skepticism in the case
of knowledge we will end with skepticism
the same would be true in ethics but i
see no more reason to do it in ethics
than in epistemology
we surely must know a great deal about
what's good for us
good for one another and we have
well-developed practices of
moral assessment that we use in our own
lives and we use
in our collective institutions so i
would say if we look to those
then we don't see just subjective
opinion it's quite
different from that and we see a lot of
constraints
so i do want to explore more arguments
around meta ethics with you and we're
intending to do that
after we discuss moral learning here now
in terms of moral epistemology and the
epistemology of meta ethics
i'm interested in this part of the
conversation and setting up and
attempting to illustrate that
whether one is going to take a skeptical
view on moral epistemology or not
the moral learning and our view on moral
epistemology
is essential and important in
the alignment and development of ai
systems
and here you're defending a more
realistic account
of epistemology and ethics well you
could say
that i myself am a realist but what i've
been saying so far
a pragmatist about ethics could say just
as well john dewey would say something
very similar
various kinds of non-realists but who
are nonetheless objectivists in ethics
kantians for example constructivists and
so on
what i've said is really neutral
territory for a wide range of views
in med ethics and doesn't presuppose in
particular a form of naturalism
or a form of realism that's actually a
tremendous
amount to build upon so that when we
think about how to design robots to
understand the world
we have a lot of knowledge about what
sorts of systems
would be well designed for doing that
similarly if we want to build a robot
who can interact
creatively and productively with other
robots
solve problems of coordination reduce
conflict realize long-term goals
interact successfully with people
recognize their interests take their
interest into account
be relatively impartial with regard to
interests that are at stake
those are not mysterious in the same way
that the skeptic seems to think they are
because again they're already integrated
in our practice and as human pointed out
a long time ago
skepticism doesn't survive very well
once we leave the
closeted philosophical study people go
out and they
act as if they had knowledge of the
world and they act as if there are
things that people could do to them or
that they could do that would be better
or worse right or wrong
they think about how they would treat
their children they think about how
they should behave with respect to their
students or their
professors that doesn't take us into the
misti realms of metaphysics
but it does take us into the practices
of moral criticism and self-criticism
so could you unpack just a little bit
more about why this view
is neutral so for example i've mentioned
a couple of features of moral thought
one feature of moral thought is that it
takes a kind of impartiality seriously
it gives equal weight
to all those affected that's something
that kantians and utilitarians and
many other moral theorists would agree
on another feature of moral thought is
that it's
concerned with general reasons similar
cases have to be treated in a similar
way
that leads to a doctrine known as
supervenience we can't
invent moral distinctions that don't
correspond to real distinctions in fact
another feature is that morality has to
do with
reciprocity relations of mutual
gain and mutual benefit another is that
morality involves taking oneself and
others
as ends and not as mere means those are
all
normative theories but if you then ask
well what about the meta ethical side
could a pragmatist about ethics say the
same things
and the answer seems to be yes the
pragmatist disease ethics is essentially
about
people solving the human problems that
they face in ways that
meet these kinds of disearada the person
who believes that there's a rationalist
foundation
believes that you can know a priori that
these constraints exist of impartiality
and so on
but as you can see from singer's work
the result of applying
his form of rationalism is not
dramatically different from the
results of applying my form of
naturalism
and that's because the target that we're
all working on
ethics that is has a great deal of
determinate structure
and so any meta-ethical theory is going
to have to capture
a lot of that structure and so sorry
what is the relationship about how this
is instructive for why metaethics
matters for ai alignment
well the suggestion was well we should
know something about what ethics is
in order to answer that question about
how we might gain
moral knowledge if we can gain moral
knowledge what moral knowledge might
consist in
that's where we started and then i tried
to suggest a bunch of considerations
a bunch of features that i could call
obvious features of
moralities of practice because i think
our practice is not just
at the normative level people also have
implicit
meta views in ethics they demonstrate
that
by for example their knowledge of how
you can determine
morally relevant considerations in
situations so they understand
what kinds of considerations are or
aren't morally relevant they understand
the distinction between morality and
etiquette
between morality and law between
morality and self-interest
so they have a grasp of a bunch of these
obvious features of morality and those
are not
just features of one or another
normative theory they're
features of virtually all normative
theories and features that any meta
ethic is going to have to
accommodate unless it's going to be
skeptical so
that's why i say that there's a great
deal of common ground
not because the fundamental explanations
are going to be the same
but there is an explanatory target which
has a great deal of structure
and which indeed all these theories have
to explain
and that requires then that meta-ethical
theories be adequate to that
i see so that is already structuring
meta-ethical epistemology is what you're
saying yeah it gives you quite a bit of
structure
yeah that's just reminding me about how
peter singer talks about this one
philosopher and his book the point of
view of the universe discusses how
there are a few axioms of morality and
they seem to touch upon these
convergent principles that you're
talking about here
now on a realists account of metaethics
there would be something like
one true moral theory and if one takes
the
one true moral theory view seriously
then the problem of ai alignment would
be
to cultivate a procedure for coming up
with the correct
moral epistemology in order to find the
one true moral theory
or to discover the one true moral theory
ourselves and then
align ai systems to that now if one
believes that there is not one
true moral theory and there is
only the evolution and extrapolation
of human normative processes and
preferences and meta preferences
then one might not want to come at the
ai alignment problem from
the perspective of a one true moral
theory approach
and as a general note i'm taking this
language from yassin gabriel who will be
on the podcast soon
and so in the secondary scenario that is
not using the one true moral theory
approach one would
want to come up with a broadly
acceptable procedure
for aligning ai systems that didn't
presume to try to discover a one true
moral theory
do you have any reactions to these two
ideas or approaches to alignment
yeah the question of whether one thinks
there is one true theory
is somewhat different from the question
of whether one
thinks we're close to it or we have good
ways of knowing it
i myself although i'm a realist i
recognize
that there's a good chance that my moral
views are wrong and my meta ethical
views are wrong
and so i don't want to just put all of
my
energy into thinking well how would we
discover the one true moral theory i
would want to think more robustly
and again if i can make an analogy with
epistemology
if you go into a philosophy of science
department or a statistics department
you'll find that there's a tremendous
debate between people who
think that bayesianism is the right kind
of approach for evidence and people who
think that
standard methods of social science are
the best methods of evidence gathering
you'll find a tremendous amount of
disagreement so if we're trying to build
a robot who understands its environment
we don't want to say well we have to
figure out which one of those theories
is correct
before we can build a robot to
understand its environment you might say
we want a robot that's got a robust
capacity to learn
and that would deliver results
reasonably approximated by
a bayesian or an inductivist or someone
using
social science statistics they're not
going to agree on everything
where there's overlap we should try to
build a machine that can say in the
overlap
we should try to build a machine that's
not brittle such that it makes epistemic
commitments
that are at the far edge of one or
another of these views
and so i would say our task is to build
a system that's robust and that means
building into it the fact that we don't
know what this one true theory is
and so therefore we want as far as
possible to
accommodate an array of approaches all
of which have
very strong reasoning behind them you
could think that we're not trying to
build
an ai system that discovers the one true
theory we're trying to build one that
isn't going to be dependent upon
exactly the target that it hits but
rather could
be successful in a array of possible
environments
so i mean adjacent to this and promoted
and
discussed by people like toby ord and
william mccaskill would be this human
existential
procedure for moving into the future
where it's like we're gonna align ai
systems whatever that means
and that alignment will hopefully not
lock in any values or any particular
kind of alignment procedure
but will ensure existential security for
humanity such that existential risk
just keeps going down to zero and is
near zero
and then we use this existentially
secure situation to
do a long reflection on value and what
is good and what may be true or not true
about
ethics and then with sufficient
consideration then we can
engage in populating the stars and
optimizing things the way that we see
fit
so what is your view on this proposed
long reflection insofar as i understand
it i don't have any
objection to it i'm not sure i do
understand it
one of the things that you mentioned
just in passing was
that we were going to try to design
these systems to
behave as we see fit i myself am not
sure i know
how it is fit to behave and i certainly
know that i have
some mistaken beliefs about that and i
would hope that just
as artificial intelligence may help us
correct certain of our views on
cosmology
or in medicine artificial intelligence
could help us correct certain of our
views and ethics
we've seen a tremendous amount of
evolution in people's fundamental moral
convictions over time
some have stayed relatively similar
others have changed dramatically
and we would i think do best to think of
the artificial extension of intelligence
as one way in which we can get a
perspective
on these issues and situations and
problems that
isn't just our own and that won't have
the same priors as
our own and won't have the same
presuppositions and they should be
included we should think of these as
as agents they will have interests just
as we have interests
and the standard would not be what do we
see fit
where we mean something like we humans
but what
will we see fit as we the humans and the
artificial systems
continue our evolution and uh our
cultural development
and we want to think that the path that
we should follow is one that leaves open
that kind of development rather than
constraining it to fit
what happens to be our current set of
moral convictions
which again are not shared there are too
many disagreements
in order to think that we could just
write down the rules
long reflection i think will also tell
us that we need a dynamic picture
and we should have some convictions that
are more confident
closer to the core we should have
methods and practices
that meet reasonable standards of
justification
and objectivity and we should be
prepared to learn
i can't i'm afraid think of a way to
guarantee against existential risk
from artificial intelligence or even our
own intelligence which may be
more problematic but i do suspect that
the
best way to contend with problems of
existential risk is to face them
as communities of inquirers all right
so i think you've done an excellent job
explaining the importance
of moral learning and moral epistemology
here given the
the ongoing cultivation of more
wholesome
and enlightened moral value and moral
thinking
is always on the horizon
now you have some perspective
and research that you've done on moral
learning
in humans and the
importance and necessity of that i'm
curious here now
then to relate some of that research
that you've done in moral learning in
humans
to how ai systems of
increasing autonomy may also wish to
take on the kind of moral epistemology
that infants and young humans may have
i wouldn't say that i've done research
in this exactly
i've certainly explored others research
in this and tried as best i can to learn
from it
one of the things that's impressed me in
the literature as it's evolved over the
last couple of decades
is how much the learning of children
is accomplished not via the explicit
teaching
but by the children's own experience
what we've learned recently and this not
from developmental psychology but from
various kinds of models of machine
learning is that
very complex structures can be learned
experientially there are powerful
techniques which we can add to that kind
of probabilistic learning in order to
create
knowledge of general principles to do
something like
build a structured understanding of
language that would enable a child to
speak fluently to understand what others
are saying and to engage with them
that does not require either an innate
grammar
or explicit instruction in language as
such
that's a kind of a model of how we also
seem to acquire
our social normative knowledge if you
think about the perspective of the
infant one thing that we've learned from
the animal research
is that animals don't just build a
spatial map in relation to themselves
they don't just build an egocentric map
of their environment
they also build grid-like maps that are
non-perspectival
and they navigate by combining these two
kinds of information
perspectival and non-perspectival
information
infants seem to do something similar in
learning
about learning they not only represent
their
relations with individual adults and
whether those benefit them or not
but they also seem to construct general
representations of whether a given adult
is competent or helpful in third-party
interactions
and to use that a perspectival
information to make decisions about who
they're going to
learn from or pay more attention to they
start doing this surprisingly early on
and so at the same time that they're
constructing the ego centered world
they're constructing a non-centered
representation of the world
that includes normative features like
reliability
competency helpfulness cooperativeness
and so the child in coming to represent
the world around them
is constructing representations that
have the
initial form of moral representations
it turns out to be efficient for
learning to be a successful human being
that one construct representations
spontaneously
that have this quasi-moral structure and
that would suggest to me that if
machines develop as agents
agents interacting with other agents
agents capable of solving a range of
problems capable of having
sustained interactions with humans to
solve open-ended problems
that they will also find that they do
better
if they can construct these quasi-moral
representations of situations
and so that means that they will be
acquiring
sensitivity to morally relevant
information
through the very task of acquiring
social competence
linguistic competence epistemic
competence
in a social world so there's a kind of
picture here
that congress nicely with the fact that
we now know that complex models can be
acquired
through experiential learning that
suggests that there is a
promising pathway toward the development
of
theory of mind causal inference
representation of social value from
uh objective or non-personal perspective
there's an argument for thinking that
that's actually a fundamental core
part of our capacity as intelligent
beings
capable of successful social interaction
that suggests that this is not
a peculiarity it's not culturally
specific
and so why not use similar methods in
our interactions with
artificial agents to enable artificial
agents to acquire
these kinds of quasi-moral mappings
so the key thing to draw out from here
is that there is this distinction
between
explicit and implicit learning of
morality
and you're remarking about how there
isn't much
explicit moral learning in infants and
children most of this moral learning
comes from simply
experience and interacting with the
world rather than explicit instruction
about
what is right and wrong there's
tremendous cultural variability in that
within our society and across societies
as to how much
explicit moral instruction children are
given what's fascinating is that even in
societies where children get very little
explicit moral instruction
they nonetheless acquire these
capacities similarly with
language there are some societies like
upper middle class
us society where parents talk
extensively with children there are
other societies where parents do not
and yet the children can become fluent
linguistic agents
so my thought is that the explicit
theory
isn't really the thing that's doing the
fundamental work
even to understand what parents are
trying to do
when they give you explicit moral
instructions understand
how to apply those or what they might
mean the child is already going to have
to have
quite a complex a perspectival
representation of the social situation
the thought here is that there's some
places explicit theory some places less
explicit theory but the result in terms
of the development of behaviors are very
similar
a good example of this is that around
age three or four
children who are given a command by an
adult in authority
if that command violates a reasonable
norm against harm
will bulk and refuse to perform it so if
a substitute teacher comes in one day
and says
i'm the teacher today and in my
classroom you have to raise your hand
before you speak
children in the classroom will start
raising their hand before they speak
if the teacher says instead i'm the
teacher here and in my classroom
children jab the point of their pencil
into the child next to them when they
wish to speak
they'll stop they won't do this and if
they're asked why
they won't say well that's not the way
we do it they'll say it would harm
the other child and so that suggests
that even an attempt by a figure in
authority
to give a norm in a situation where
children can perfectly
understand that there is a scope of
legitimate authority
put your hand up before you speak they
will distinguish between that kind of
conventional
authority and moral authority and that's
an autonomous
action on their part they're not getting
rewarded for it in fact the teachers may
be going to send them out of the room
send a note home to their parents but
they bulk because they
can represent the situation in these
quasi-moral terms
and when they do that they say no this
is not a good solution to the problem
that suggests to me that even if we were
to think
that children learn by being given
explicit instructions by people in
authority
they actually independently learn that
they can resist that and will resist it
right so we're in a position
where evolution has cultivated
and embedded in us a kind of moral
learning
where there is a certain degree of
implicit and
explicit moral learning depending on
your culture and where you're from
and as you're saying luckily
there's strong convergence on this
ability of moral learning to
lead human beings to agreeing on
say in the case of stabbing the other
child that would be something like
a principle of unnecessary harm to
another person
that seems to be for most human beings
something that is like strongly
converged upon
pretty early unless your environment is
particularly
pernicious or something and the there is
this convergence because of how our
moral learning is structured given
evolution
and that that moral learning enables
in us a kind of moral autonomy that's
there from an early age
and there was a question of how this
moral learning
is best structured in
say both people and in machine systems
and then there's the question of moral
learning
from the outside what kind of
environment is most conducive to moral
learning
are there insights into this that can
begin
pivoting us into the relationship or
importance of moral learning and ai
systems perhaps so
actually there's a fair amount of
evidence that even infants brought up in
some very difficult situations
will nonetheless develop these forms of
pro-sociality
and cooperativeness partly because they
become especially
important in those situations even to
solving the most basic problems or
meeting the most basic needs
so i wouldn't think that the mere
difficulty of the situation
was sufficient to prevent this kind of
learning on the other hand
if the child is given the wrong
incentives they're also going to learn a
whole bunch of other stuff
like you can't count on other people you
can't trust other people
so put this from the standpoint of
artificial agents
we want the artificial agents in our
world whether they're a
companion for an elderly person or an
autonomous
vehicle or a telephone answering
service system we want those systems
to be sensitive to these kinds of moral
considerations
and capable of a degree of autonomy
if for example there is a system that's
looking after an elderly person and some
vital sign of the elderly person is
showing a problem
and the person says i don't want to
report that i don't like
having people know this information
about me or maybe they're concerned that
the doctor will prescribe something that
they won't like
i hope to have systems which can in that
situation think
is this the kind of thing that i should
keep
from the physician it's the preference
of this individual
but this preference may not be the best
interest of the individual in this case
and so an autonomous system would be
able to
make that kind of assessment could get
it wrong could get it right could learn
from it
but i wouldn't want a system to be such
that they would simply take over
wholesale the preferences of the person
that they're interacting with and of
course the same thing is going to be
true with self-driving cars and with
question answering systems and so on
they will need a certain amount of
autonomy
in order to those jobs effectively
and in order for that to happen for them
to have that autonomy they'll have to
have their own representations
of the moral structures of the
situations
and have the capacity to construct those
i
suspect that if we really do want to
create intelligent
systems that are capable of this kind of
autonomous self-critical and critical
moral thought
the way to do so is very much like the
way children do so
and in so doing we run the risk of
creating some autonomy
the systems won't always agree with us
but
have we done what's appropriate so that
when they exercise that autonomy
their chance of getting things right is
is good at least is our chance of
getting things right
so you could think of this in the kind
of adversarial
picture where you're trying to see if
you can discriminate between the
moral judgments of the machine and the
moral judgments of the individual
and the machine and the individual could
be
part of a learning process that improves
the
machine's overall model and generative
model of situations
so there would be the question of how do
you structure a system
such that it can learn moral learning
in a way that would be
broadly endorsed or would satisfy
other ethical or meta-ethical principles
that we have
that is double-edged insofar as if you
screw it up then
the thing is autonomous and can disagree
with you
and the capacity to disagree would
either be detrimental
in the case in which it is wrong in its
moral learning or it would be
enlightening
for both us and the world and and the
machine if it were
right about morality when we weren't
how do you think about and balance this
risk between
the possible enlightenment that may come
from embedding ai systems with moral
learning
and also the potential catastrophe if
it's done
too quickly and incorrectly yeah wish i
had an answer
if you think about it the existence of
humans
with malicious intentions means that if
artificially intelligent systems don't
have this kind of moral autonomy
they're going to be very willing
servants so you might say well there's a
risk on the other side which is that if
they
aren't capable of any kind of criticism
or autonomy
then they will be much too willing and
much too readily deployed
and much too manipulable by humans whose
purposes i'm afraid to say are not
always benign
if you were thinking about the problem
of raising a child you would say well i
don't want to raise a child who simply
take
orders i want to raise a child who can
raise questions
as well i think our only defense against
malicious humans with extremely
intelligent systems at their disposal
is to try to ally with intelligence
systems to create a comparable
and that counterforce is going to be
operating out way past
our understanding because it's going to
be in competition with
systems that can operate extremely fast
and take into account a large number of
variables
and so we'd better be building systems
which as they get further and further
out in this kind of a competition have
some kind of a core
where they are responsive to morally
relevant features
even at the far extent of their
development and so
if you think about it as trying to build
a moral core
then that core can figure in their
operation
even as they become more and more
intelligent they can use the
intelligence to gain information and
perspective and capacity
to understand situations that can
improve their understanding
but if we don't do something like this
we will really be
and other artificial systems will be
prey to
those who have and want to implement
malicious and
manipulative intentions so i balance the
risk partly by thinking
i can't think of a very good way to
defend
against the perils of malicious
combinations of human and artificial
intelligence
other than to develop more trustworthy
forms of human and artificial
intelligence interaction and that
requires according
these systems some autonomy and some
trust
that makes sense to me and i think it
addresses some important dimensions of
the soon-to-be proliferation of ai
to me one of the most exciting features
of
more recent developments in artificial
intelligence is that they give us for
the first time
i think a plausible model of intuitive
knowledge
a knowledge that it could be implicit
but nonetheless be
highly structured contain a great deal
of information containing capacity to
engage in
a simulation and evaluation
so i would expect that the structure of
moral knowledge
could be like our structure of common
sense knowledge generally
could be quite distributed it could be
quite a complicated
system not a system of extracted
principles there might be some
general features that are important i
think that's bound to be true
and that is true when these systems
learn
but we don't have to think that the kind
of competency that they would have
if it isn't something like that is
therefore undisciplined
therefore lacks power or reliability
so for the first time anyhow i thought
here is a picture of how
intuitive intelligence might look and of
course we can't introspect
the structure of such knowledge and it
does not have
a readily introspectible propositional
structure but it
is capable nonetheless of carrying and
modeling
and engaging in quite complex
computations
simulations action guidance control of
motor systems
in ways that look like intuitive
intelligence
now i realize we're a long way from the
way the brain actually functions
but even to have these models it gives
us a kind of
proof of concept of the possibility of
something like intuitive knowledge
right so if we're building ai systems as
willing slaves who optimize the
preferences of whoever is able to embed
those in the machine
there's no defense in that world against
malevolent preferences other than not
allowing the proliferation of ai
to begin with and we're already past
that point
enough has proliferated and there's
enough inequality of wealth and power in
the world
to guarantee that other proliferation
will take place
it's already the case that we can't
count on keeping this genie in the
bottle
and obviously don't want to do so i'd
say we're now in the phase where we need
to have an active constructive program
of starting to build ai agents that are
actively responsive to
morally relevant considerations are good
at
solving coordination problems a good at
this kind of interaction
and capable of the kind of insight
needed to be
potential moral agents right and you
argue that
as these systems inhabit increasingly
social roles
in society and are constantly
interacting with other agents and with
the world it's
increasingly important that they be
sensitive to morally relevant features
without this again malevolent humans or
humans with
misaligned values that are counter to
most of the rest of
humanity can abuse or use systems more
freely
if they're not already sensitive to
morally relevant features
and that if there is an ecosystem of ais
purely altruistic systems which are not
tuned in to morally relevant features
can be
abused by other ais as well yes that's
right
one thing that's gotten me to feel some
conviction about this
possibility is that the one kind of
experiments that i do run are thought
experiments
and i've been for years running moral
thought experiments
in my moral philosophy classes and in
recent
years i've been able to do so using a
system that allows students to
confidentially record their
answers to problems like moral dilemmas
or
questions about interpreting moral
situations or motives
and what's impressed me over the years
is how
coherent and consistent these responses
are
and what left out for example from the
familiar trolley problem
was that mediating their moral judgments
seemed to be
a model of the agents that are involved
a model of what kind of an agent would
perform an action of a certain kind
and what kind of responses such an agent
would
receive from others in the community
would they be trustworthy would they not
be trustworthy
and so instead of thinking there's just
these arbitrary differences in
preference between throwing a switch and
pushing someone off a footbridge
and there's no real principle there and
no one's found a principle to cover
these cases you can think no there's
this intuitive competency people
have in understanding situations and
characters and
what kinds of persons would respond in
what ways and situations and what it
would be like to have those persons in
our community
and once you look at it that way you can
a tremendous amount
of consistency in people's responses
which suggested to me that they are
doing this kind of generative modeling
of situations
and doing so in a way that does predict
to their
actual judgments and if i ask well why
did you make that judgment they'll say i
don't know it was just an intuition
yeah so the thought experiment that
you're pointing to
a lot of people would flip the switch in
the trolley
thought experiment to switch it to the
track where there's only one person
and then if you change it so that
there's a person on a bridge who's
sufficiently large that if you push them
off the bridge they will
stop the trolley from killing five
people on the track
the intuitive response that you're
pointing out is that people
are less likely to want to push someone
off of a bridge
than to flip a switch and you're like
well what's really the difference
in the thought experiment there's not
much of a difference but the
intuition that you're pointing out the
morally relevant feature that is
subtle and implicit is that we don't
want to live in a world
where there are the kinds of people who
have the capacity to push people off of
bridges in that kind of a setting yes
yeah
and you can give them a whole array of
other scenarios
in which the agent would have to do
something like pushing someone
to a grisly death and where they will
agree that it
should be done for example in situations
where
self-defense is needed against for
example the terrorist action
and again you've asked them well would
you trust an agent who would perform
such an
action then the answer is they would
actually have more trust
in such an agent so again they're
modeling the situation not
in response to this or that minor tweak
of the situational features
but in terms of a quite deep
understanding of the
motivations and attitudes that are
involved and then if you go over to the
psychological literature you find that
dispositions to give the push verdict in
the footbridge case
correlate more with antisocial behavior
with lack of altruism with lack of
perspective taking
with indifference to harm than with
altruism
or any kind of generalized utilitarian
perspective
so the psychologist seemed to confirm
the understanding that my students
implicitly had of the situation
what's relevant to extract here is that
there
are deep levels of morally salient
features
that human beings take into account and
that are increasingly
needed to be modeled and understood
by machine systems for them to
successfully operate in the world
yeah and to be trustworthy i'm
one of those people who thinks emotion
is not a magical substance either and
that
artificial systems could have and
acquire emotions
and that part of the answer to the
question of
how do you build a core that is
resistant against certain types of
manipulation
is to look at how it's done in humans
and indeed in other animals
and discover that the affective system
plays a pivotal role
in just these kinds of situations and so
i suspect that's another avenue of
development
and children's moral emotions undergo a
similar kind of evolution through their
upbringing but through their direct
experience
because the emotions are there before
they're told what to feel
indeed how would you tell the child what
to feel
are there any other points that you'd
like to wrap up here on then
on the advantages of reflecting on ai's
which are sensitive to morally relevant
features
you know i try to be as accurate as i
can in understanding what we're learning
from the
literature on pro-sociality for example
both with regard to individual human
development and with regard to
human communities going back looking at
hunter-gatherer communities
and even as there have been changes in
morality and i've emphasized that
there's been changes over time
the kinds of features that people take
to be morally relevant
many of those have been relatively
constant and
you can think of our changes in our
moral views that have taken place over
the years is getting better and better
at winnowing out the ones that
aren't really more relevant like gender
ethnicity
sexual orientation and so on because
they can easily become culturally
relevant without being morally relevant
fortunately
we have the critical capacity as agents
to challenge that
yeah that makes sense the core
importance that i'm extracting from
everything
is the baseline importance of moral
learning in general
and also the understanding and capturing
what human normative processes are like
and what they entail and how they
unfold and that participating
in a world of humans
requires knowledge of both moral
learning
and the ability to learn morally and
this is not saying that people will
always behave well
just in the same way that acquiring
linguistic competence doesn't mean
people are always going to speak well or
truthfully or honestly
but rather that the competency will be
acquired
one example that i like is sexual
orientation
when i was growing up it was considered
fatal
for someone's social identity to be
discovered to be gay
and there was a great deal of belief
about the
characteristics of gay individuals in
the
90s and so on a large number of gay
individuals were courageous enough
to indicate their orientation
and what was discovered we all
discovered was that the
world was full of gay individuals whom
we admired whom we had standard
relationships with
who were excellent colleagues co-workers
friends
and that therefore we were operating on
a bad data set
because we had not really had we here
i'm talking about heterosexuals
had insufficient experience with gay
individuals and so we could believe all
kinds of things about them
so i would emphasize that if it's a
learning system it's going to be very
sensitive to the data
and if the data's bad the learning
system is going to have a problem
so i don't think it's a magic solution
but i think the question to ask is
so how do we build on this how do we
provide
more representative experiences and less
biased
samples so that the learning can take
place and not
pick up cultural biases yeah
those are really big problems that exist
today and a lot of the solution
right now is human beings having to do a
lot of hard work in data sets
we can't keep that up forever something
else is needed
i think this has been instructive about
the importance and structure of moral
learning and
i want to pivot back into our discussion
of meta ethics and your conversations
with derek parfit and what your
meta-ethical view is
and how views on meta-ethical
epistemology or metaphysics may
bring to bear intuitions about what
moral learning is like or what it
might entail it's derek parfitt right
who has essays on does anything really
matter
yeah so i guess that's the question here
then for this part of the conversation
is
does anything really matter so
you were in conversation with derek
parfit and it seems like your
views have converged and are different
in ways from
peter singers though it seems like you
guys are all realists
could you unpack and explain a little
bit about the history here and
what went down between you par fit and
singer
yeah sure this is i have to warn those
who are listening you know buckle up
this is
going to have to be a philosophy talk
but i'm sure that
many people have these philosophical
questions themselves
so let's just begin with the title that
parfait chose for his
master work on what matters is the title
and you might say that mattering is
the core notion of value
that if you had a universe full of rocks
it would not matter to the rocks what
happened it would not matter to the rest
of the universe
what happened and so there wouldn't be
any
positive or negative value in that
universe
introduce creatures for whom something
matters even if it's just as simple
as nutrition or avoiding pain
then you can begin to talk about states
of affairs being better or worse than
one another
about improving or degrading the
situation or the characteristics of the
world
and so mattering is poor to the idea of
value
and once we grasp that we begin to
realize that value
is not some new entity in the world it's
not something we
add to the world once you have mattering
then things will have value
and they'll have positive and they'll
have negative value
and of course for different creatures
different things will matter and
learning what matters to a creature is
understanding what would be
good or harmful to that creature and
this of course includes humans
so i was very moved when i was on a
committee
looking into questions of animal
research to know that the veterinarians
learned a lot about what situations
animals preferred and did what they
could to try to give them
situations in which they were happier
more lively
more disposed to cooperate and learn
and that means that they were trying to
learn something about what matters to a
rat
and we now know a fair amount about what
matters to rat company
matters uh exercise the capacity to
engage in activities
build nests and so these things matter
to rats and so we can give rats a good
or a bad existence
by thinking about well what does matter
to rats now what matters to rats is
different from what matters to humans
but the basic idea is the same so there
is value there
and it's thanks to the existence of
creatures for whom something matters
that value comes into existence in the
world
that's a perfectly naturalistic
perspective treating
value as something that is realized by
natural states of affairs in the world
now it turns out that even someone who's
an arch non-naturalist
like derek parfit agrees that pain is
bad not because it has
the non-natural property of being
disvaluable
but because of what it's like in its
natural features
those features suffice to make the pain
bad
and if they didn't suffice to make the
pain bad there would be no
value feature we could sprinkle on it
that would make it bad
but given that it has those features
there is also no value feature we can
sprinkle on it that will make it
good and so parfait and i can agree
that non-naturalism is important in
ethics
not because the world is populated with
non-natural entities
like values that's a widespread
confusion
it's reifying a notion of value as if it
were some kind of a
new domain of entities and actually once
you've done that it becomes very unclear
how we learn about these
what relationship they have to the
natural world if instead you think
no value is something that is brought
into existence by certain relational
features
in the natural world then you can say ah
that's common ground
between derek parfit and myself
and if derek's explaining what's bad
about pain he'll give the same
explanation that i would give
about what's bad about pain so we agree
on that the badness in the case of
pain pain is really used for two
different things
it's used for certain types of physical
sensation and it's used for suffering
that physical sensation isn't always
suffering
so for example when you put hot sauce on
your food you
fire up pain circuits but you enjoy that
you may seek the burn of exercise
and so there are times when the physical
sensation of pain
is sought and liked desirable it's part
of good experiences
it shows that pain can matter in
different ways it's the mattering
where the value resides not in the
physical sensation just
in itself so the mattering is a
relationship
between a subjectivity an agent and
the physical sensation and it could be
positive or negative in a given case but
the
value resides in that relationship but
they're just two
contents of consciousness right there is
the content of consciousness of the the
sensation of
pain on my arm if i scratch it
and i might derive another sensation
from that sensual pain that is pleasure
wouldn't the goodness here need to come
from this higher level more
pristine pleasure that i gain from the
pain
which is more of an emotion and which is
intuitive to the other sensation or the
other content of consciousness
well i think you're right to bring in
higher level
mental states as well because part of
the reason
why pain in certain circumstances is
desirable
is because of the representation that
you have of it
and this is true with many features of
the world it's because you understand
them in certain ways that they
produce in you the positive or negative
experience they do
and if you ask a psychologist the
positivity and the negativity
in the mind does not reside in the
impulses
of the pain system or the pleasure or
reward system
it resides in the affective system which
encodes value
as positive or negative and it encodes
as well
the behaviors and the responses that are
characteristic of positive and negative
value
positive is approach negative is
withdrawal fear
involves a certain distinctive suite of
responses
anger involves another distinctive suite
of responses but the affective system
is where the value is encoded and that's
the common currency
of value in the brain so that's where we
should be looking to
discover and it's the affective system
that which is the
root of our emotions whether they're
aroused emotions like anger or fear
or non-aroused emotions like assurance
and
trust that system is a system which
encodes this relational feature of value
you're quite right to think that we
should move up a level
and in doing so we encounter the
effective system and its properties
and it's a system that we share with all
of our mammalian relatives and with
other species as well it's
evolutionarily a highly conserved system
and that's because it is the core of
valuation
and valuation is a poor activity of
living creatures because they're going
to base their actions
on value assignments you're right to
think that in the mind
you will have tears and that you need to
find the right level
in order to understand what value or dis
value looks like
in the mind so there's
the view where some content of
consciousness
is clearly seen as bad given its nature
if some state of consciousness is
like something from a consciousness
realist perspective
and it is also natural because it's part
of
the natural world it's a physical fact
and there are facts about
consciousness then value comes in from
what it's like to be conscious whereas
it seems like you're bringing in
the moral computational and physical
side of things like an
evaluative affective system which
may not be separate from how things are
experienced in consciousness but i feel
confused about these two different
levels and where
the what matters comes from
well yes you're quite right there are
views
about value in which it's only conscious
states
that could have value or dis value i
don't prickly
hold such a view i think that we are
intrinsically concerned with
and that there is intrinsic value in
non-conscious states
and that's why i wouldn't sign up for
the experience machine
the experience machine could provide an
unending stream supposedly
of positive conscious states but why
wouldn't i
sign on for it well because the actual
content of my values
is not that i have certain conscious
states it's that i have
certain relations with people with the
external world
that i have a certain engagement with
things that have a
consciousness and that matter and so
i wouldn't agree that the only place the
only locus of value or dis value is
conscious states
so then from a cosmological and
evolutionary perspective there has been
the development and arising of sentient
creatures on this planet
who have ever complexifying neural
algorithms for modeling themselves and
the world and making predictions and
interacting with it
and amongst these evolved architectures
include evaluative
ones which take the shape of valuing or
dis valuing
certain aspects of the world and so that
is enough for you for talking about
intrinsic value you feel like you don't
need to bring consciousness into it
you're fine with just talking about the
computation
oh i think consciousness plays a role
because one of the good making features
is a positive state of consciousness
it's just it's not the only one
and so there are differences in the
world that would not show up as
differences in conscious states
and that's what the experience machine
is meant to show but which would
nonetheless
constitute things that matter in the
sense of matter that we were just
describing
namely that these are objects of concern
love
affection interest on the positive side
objects of dislike disevaluation
disapproval on the
negative side i don't think there's any
reason to think
that only conscious states can be locus
as a value but it may be
that consciousness plays a role so what
are these other good making features and
why are they good making
well take for example a theory like a
preference
satisfaction theory i would prefer other
things equal
that after i'm gone my children have
lives
that they find meaningful now is that
because i want to have the
positive experience of thinking that
their lives are meaningful
no i want them to have those lives and
so it's part of the content of my
informed preferences let's say that they
would survive information
it's part of the content of my informed
preferences that the world be such that
my children have a certain kind of life
and you say well doesn't the
meaningfulness of their life just
consist in their conscious dates and i
say well no not at all i would think
that a life and an experience machine
would have the same meaning
as a life with similar stream of
conscious states that was lived
in engagement with the world and so when
i want them to have meaningful lives i
want them to have lives in which they
act in ways that matter to them and that
they do things that matter
to themselves and to others and their
intrinsic preferences like my
intrinsic preferences aren't just going
to be for conscious states
and so it may be that you need something
like preference
or interest to get value off the ground
mattering
but the content of what interests us or
the content of what our preferences are
won't just be the conscious states so
you can't satisfy my preferences just by
giving me conscious states for example
so i don't share that intuition with you
i still don't understand why you feel
that something like a preference is good
making
i guess that just comes down to
intuitions i mean what someone could ask
me why do i think consciousness is the
only thing that is good making but i
don't know what is a preference
it's like a concept about some
computational architecture that
prefers some state of the world over
another
but when you pass away for example your
preference goes away so
why does it need to be respected still i
mean we're getting into some waters here
but
is the short version of this that when
you just do these philosophical thought
experiments that
your intuitions aren't satisfied by
consciousness being
necessary and sufficient for value well
all of our knowledge whether it's
knowledge of value or the external world
we can push it back to a point in which
again we can't
give some further derivation of the
assumption that we're making
and so my thinking here is that it seems
to me
extremely plausible that the one
intelligible notion i can get
of something like value is that there
can be a subjectivity
such that states of affairs can go
better or worse for that subjectivity
and then value would consist in that
which makes
the states of affairs better or worse
for that individual
and then i asked myself well does that
satisfy our concept of value
well value should have various different
features and we can list those it should
be something that when we understand
it's intrinsically motivating
it should apply to the sorts of things
that we ordinarily identify as being
values
it should capture a certain role in the
guidance of action
it should be something like a goal in
action we should see it as
structuring the behavior of individuals
and when i look at all those conditions
i think yeah this satisfies those
conditions
it's not a proof it's just saying that
if we lay down the conditions that we
would give for something
satisfying the concept of value these
states do indeed
satisfy those conditions and that many
other candidate states don't
but i can't tell you for example that
you shouldn't have some other concept
of calu instead of value and ask what
would satisfy calu
in the same way that i can't in the case
of knowledge of the external world
give you a derivation of the importance
of
knowledge as opposed to shmalage
we can operate with the concept of
knowledge and see what it requires and
see whether it would apply to what we
are doing but that's not a proof
that there isn't another scheme of
shmalage of which the same thing could
be said
so that's where we get down to these
fundamental assumptions
and can they be non-arbitrary well they
can for example
if when applying them you can be put in
a situation where you give them up
a concept that we had that we thought we
were happy with turns out to be confused
or it turns out that the only things
that would satisfy the concept are
things which we
ordinarily think the concept doesn't
apply to so we think there's a mismatch
between the criteria
and the paradigm cases so it's not
arbitrary if you're willing to use it
critically
but it can't be proven okay a bit of a
side path from where you were at par fit
i was curious about
what you really meant by how you guys
were agreeing about
value being some natural thing
instead of having to sprinkle value
the way i would put it the disagreement
that i have with parfit
is a disagreement at the conceptual
level
initially at any rate it looked like we
had
a conflict of opinions because it looked
as if
he was committed to their being in the
world these non-natural features
and that they somehow explained the role
that value has in our lives and i
couldn't understand what that would mean
but he was perfectly content to say no
the good making features are these
natural features they explain the role
that value has
in our lives but our concept of value
is a non-natural concept and what does
it mean to say that
well the same situation the same
configuration of matter
could be described with physical
concepts chemical concepts
biological concepts oh it's an organism
it could be described in social concepts
it's a person any given situation can be
characterized in various different
conceptual systems
and it can be argued plausibly that you
can't reduce
for example the conceptual system of
biology to the conceptual system of
particle physics because biology deals
in
functions reproduction metabolism and so
on
and there's no one-to-one correspondence
no easy correspondence between
those functions and any particular
physical realization
you could have living beings made out of
carbon you could have living beings made
out of
silicon so the concept of living being
the concept of an
organism is a concept of biology it's a
way to organize
the description of the world into
explanation and
biology is conceptually not reducible to
physics that doesn't mean biologists can
ignore physics because they think
most anyhow do that what satisfies their
biological concepts
are physical systems and so it's an
important question
what kinds of physical systems satisfy
these concepts like self-replication and
so on
and so they do microbiology and they
study the physical systems that do
satisfy these concepts
but the point is that the conceptual
system has a degree of autonomy
from the physical system and that even
discovering
that self-replicating molecules have a
certain chemical composition
in this world is not discovering that
the concept of a self-replicating
organism is simply a physical concept
parvat has the same view about
normative concepts he and i agree about
what pain is
and what makes pain bad but he says you
could describe a situation
either as you were saying in terms of
some physical
biochemical processes or you could
describe it as
bad or as good or something that ought
not to exist
and that's another level of conceptual
characterization
and his thought is that that level of
conceptual characterization can't be
reduced
to the concepts of natural order
so there is an element in normative
concepts
that's always beyond what is
translatable without
loss of meaning into the natural
once one recognizes that then you can be
as naturalistic as you like about the
nature of value
and also believe that the concept of
value is a non-natural concept
just as if you can be as physicalist as
you like about the fundamental furniture
of the universe
and still believe that the biological
level of description is not reducible to
the physical level of description
you could say the same debate went on
when people were thinking about life
19th century we find people thinking
well there's got to be this special elon
vital or spirit or something like that
you can't just take a bunch of matter
and put it together and have life
by and by biochemistry develops and
people actually you can put a bunch of
matter together and have life and the
same thing is true with value
you don't need some value vital some
kind of further substance to add to the
world
you can put together the natural stuff
of the world and get value
once you frame it that way then parfait
and i actually agree
because when he talks about the
irreducibility of the normative
he really means should mean and i think
agrees that he means
a conceptual irreducibility and once we
establish that then i can say yes i
agree with you normative concepts aren't
definable entirely in terms of
non-normative concepts they involve some
idea of ought or
some idea of value that isn't present in
the non-normative
but my interest as a philosopher
metathesis
is an interest in what kinds of natural
conditions
satisfy these concepts and how that
makes it possible for us to have
knowledge
in a non-normative conceptual scheme
like ethics
or theory of value so that's where i do
my work
his work is done in carefully
distinguishing the concepts
so there is reality as it is there is
the base reality based metaphysics call
it ultimate reality or whatever
and all human conceptualization
supervenes upon that because it's
couched within that context and is
identical to it
yet that conceptualization you argue
is lossy with respect to ultimate
reality
because it doesn't necessarily carve
reality at the joints
but that conceptual structure is still
super convenient upon it
and at the level of conceptualization
there are facts about the world that can
be satisfied or not satisfied
that will make some proposition true or
false
yeah so you're arguing that value isn't
part of
metaphysical bedrock but metaphysical
bedrock
creates neural architectures that create
concepts
that contain within them necessary and
sufficient conditions for being
satisfied
and when agents are able to gain clarity
with one another over concepts
and satisfying necessary and sufficient
conditions
then they can have concrete discussions
about
ethics that would be one common basis
and so the image that parfit gave in his
first volume of on what matters was that
he thought ultimately you could see the
utilitarian and the kantian as climbing
two different sides of the same mountain
so that they would eventually meet at
the summit
i suggested to him well in metaethics
the same is the case
i'm a naturalist i'm climbing one side
of the mountain you're a non-naturalist
you're climbing the other side of the
mountain
but as our views develop and as we
understand
better the different elements of the
views then actually they're going to
come
such that as we approach the summit we
aren't really disagreeing with each
other
and he accepted that picture i would
only add to what you were saying by way
of summary
our concepts typically don't give us
necessary and sufficient conditions
they are more open-ended and
open-textured than that
and that's part of why we can have
unending debates about questions like
value and so on
but you mentioned truth and you might
say true is another very good
example of a concept that's not
reducible to a concept of physics
because true presupposes representations
and representations
are characterizable not in terms of
their physical constituents
but in terms of their role in thought
and so
people who are skeptical about value
because they say i don't see where value
is in the world
they should be equally skeptical about
truth because truth is not some new
substance we add
if there's a representation and it
accurately reflects the world then we
have truth
so true again is a relational matter
between a
subject something like a representation
and
this case a state of the world and it's
when that relationship
obtains that you get truth right but
that's truth in the epistemological
agent-centered sense but then there's a
more metaphysical view about truth where
there are mind-independent facts
and they're true whether or not we know
anything about them
maybe the same distinction is important
here to make there
are potentially moral truths within
the conceptual framework that we're
participating in
and it feels weird to me to call that
moral realism but then there's another
claim
where there's mind independent truths
about morality
like that there's an intrinsic quality
to suffering
that is what bad means does that make
sense
i think you put things in a very good
way
one of the features of the kind of setup
that i was describing
is that it's very easy to slide
from a position that for example
whenever
a value judgment obtains then some or
other natural state obtains
it's very easy to slide from that to
thinking that
the natural state actually is the
normative fact it doesn't satisfy the
concept and so
you could have the concept of the good
and it could be that there are eternal
truths about good i suspect that's a
reasonable candidate just as there can
be
eternal truths in mathematics the claim
isn't
that the conceptual domain is somehow
identical with the natural domain
it supervenes but it's not a
relationship of identity
and the language in which those claims
are stated and the way in which we
adjudicate them
might be as in the case of mathematical
claims it could be quite a priori
and that's where parfait's view and mind
differ than singers
likewise because he thinks you can do
this a priori in a way that i don't
think you can but that's a question in
epistemology
it doesn't require a different
metaphysics in order to have that view
so you can be a physicalist and believe
that there is mathematical truth
and that's because for example you think
that mathematical truths are true
via a set of axioms definitions
rules of inference and so they are made
true
not by distributions of molecules but
by logical relationships that can be
specified in terms of axioms and rules
okay
so i feel a little bit confused still
about why
your view is a kind of moral realism if
it requires
no strong metaphysical view
whereas other moral realists that i'm
familiar with hold a strong metaphysical
view
about suffering in consciousness and
enjoying consciousness as being
the intrinsic valence carriers of value
well i'm not sure about the last part of
your question i'll have to
think about how to interpret that but at
my realists
about organisms if i believe
that the concept of an organism is
distinct
from any particular physical
instantiation
do my prevented from being a realist
about organisms because
i think the organismic level of
description
is irreducible to the physical level of
description you see no
actually because you think that the
concept organism is satisfied by some
physical system
you're a realist about organisms you
think there are organisms
to me that's a perfectly realistic
position and your realist
or non-realist would say well i guess
there aren't any organisms then because
they're not part of the fundamental
furniture of the universe
and i'd say think of what an organism is
it's not
a piece of furniture it's a functionally
organized
arrangement and because it's
functionally organized it doesn't
correspond to any particular material
something or other
and for there to exist organisms is for
there to exist the conditions such that
the concept of organism is
satisfied and that's of course what most
biologists believe
and so most biologists are realists
about organisms
if your intuitions changed about the
reducibility of higher levels of
knowledge to lower
levels of knowledge how would that
affect your moral views
for example there are views say like
concepts in biology about reproduction
and organisms and
concepts like life are lossy when it
comes to
the actual furniture of reality and that
they don't actually
completely describe how things are and
the concepts don't carve reality at the
joints so
they provide predictions about the world
but
it all should be and is only best
described by
particle physics for example one might
say
an organism is a concept though it does
not carve reality at the joints
and a best understanding of it is at the
level of particle physics
so taking a realist position about
conceptual fictions is dubious
to define reality as whenever some
concept i have is
satisfied what you're pointing to is a
very interesting
problem i would say that biological
concepts
do carve things at the joint because the
biological level of organization
yields a whole systematic set of laws
and principles
that turn out to be true in our universe
it's far from being an arbitrary
stipulation or a fiction that
something's an organism
and a tremendous amount follows from
things being organisms and
self-replicating and so on and we
have a very elaborate theories about
populations
mathematics and populations and are
those laws though not reducible to other
laws
that's the idea that reducibility is the
wrong concept to have here
because the laws of population are laws
that have to do with variables that
aren't fundamental variables of physics
they have to do with for example issues
about reproducibility
availability of resources and so on and
what counts as a resource depends upon
the nature of the organism
so there's a level of organization
similarly in chemistry
but what if those variables are just the
shape
of lower level things well they won't be
because if there were self-reproducing
silicon based organisms they would obey
similar population dynamics those
principles
govern functional organizations so once
you have self-replication
you have mutation you have differential
selection and so on
you'll get certain principles whatever
physical
realization there is but it really
doesn't make sense to me
that these higher level laws would not
be completely super convenient on
fundamental forces of nature
oh they're super convenient definitely
but super venus does not imply
reduceability
that's really critical in this domain
and again this is the problem that i
think has led to
a lot of confusion in this domain a
feature that is
super venient upon fundamental physics
is perhaps part
of a system of laws that provides
joints in nature because if you went to
another world and you found a form of
life
that had these basic features of
self-replication
mutation selection you would expect to
find
similar population dynamics to earth and
that similarity
is a biological similarity it's not a
similarity in terms of the basic
physics of the situation the physics are
the same but the constitution of these
organisms is very different
and so you couldn't infer from
understanding just the physics that
there would be this biological
regularity that's what it means to say
that it's super veniant but not
reducible
again i think you can be a realist about
organisms because
organism really is a concept that cars
nature at the joints
and so we would be able to export our
theory of organisms
to worlds in which carbon was not
abundant
and self-replication was built out of
something else and
that's a way in which nature is lawfully
organized supports counterfactuals
supports explanations
and so that's a way of thinking about
what it means to say
it's super venient but not reducible
and i think the same thing is true with
moral distinctions and that's why
they're
learnable that's why infants can learn
moral distinctions even without being
given moral concepts
yeah so that's why i'm pushing on this
point now
that makes more sense to me in terms of
moral statements
but when trying to make physical claims
about how reality is
i feel more confused here and maybe it's
messing me up in other places
if all of causality is governed by
fundamental forces
then surely all concepts that try to map
out the world that is being governed by
fundamental causality all the laws that
are
derived at higher levels must be
completely reducible to and super venue
upon or
lossy to some extent with relation to
the fundamental
causal forces i don't think the claim is
that for example
principles of biology and life are
causal in themselves
they're more like laws that we use to
make predictions
but predictions about systems that are
running
on the fundamental laws of nature
the complex aggregation of those laws
must aggregate in some way to
come close to those laws of biology
what is wrong with this picture well
there may be nothing wrong with it
i think the laws of biology are not just
descriptive
i think they support explanations and
that they are
used not just to redescribe reality
but they're used to construct theories
that show
structure in reality that's extremely
important structure and that would not
be visible
simply if you allowed only predicates of
fundamental physics i guess i would say
from the standpoint of explanation
biology affords many explanations
you know suppose somebody wants to know
why the material that
happens to be in my body is where it is
right now
well there is some very complicated
story at the level of fundamental
microphysics following all of these
molecules but it doesn't look like
anything at all
whereas if you can give an explanation
in terms of evolution
and social dynamics as to how these
molecules got here
you may have a much more compact
comprehensible
and understanding grasp of the world
so i think biology affords us distinct
modes of understanding and explanation
so does psychology so does chemistry one
of the features of knowledge
is that reality is organized at various
levels
in systems that are lawful systems
and that support explanation and
intervention
and causation there's no reason not to
call this causation
and so if somebody's describing the
spread of the pandemic
and they say well it's partially caused
by the transmissibility of the virus
which is higher than that of the
bird flu we'll say yes that's a causal
factor
in the spread of the virus and why these
particular molecules are located in the
world where they are
and that's a very powerful explanation
and if someone were just giving you a
readout of the
positions and momenta of all the
different molecules of the world you
would not see this pattern
and you'd have less understanding of the
situation
so tying this into your meta ethics here
our ethical concepts are causally
supervising on fundamental forces on
physics
we've inherited them via evolution and
they run on physics
but these concepts do not reduce to
natural facts
there's no goodness or badness
built into the fundamental nature of the
universe these concepts are merely
causal expressions of the universe
playing out and within the realm
of this conceptualization you can
have truths about morality
in the same way that you can have truths
about biological organisms
and there's a relationship here between
what you might believe to be true about
conceptualization and science and the
epistemic status of concepts in general
would also bear some information here
on how one might think about the
epistemic status
of moral concepts yeah or thinking in
terms of
algorithms and systems a systems
theoretic perspective gives you
a lot of very well organized
understanding once you grasp the
algorithms that are at work and so on
but algorithm is not a concept of
fundamental physics
right so it's your view that moral facts
moral claims within conceptualization
hold the same
epistemic status as claims about
algorithms and biological organisms and
claims that we might make in things like
chemistry or biology
which are at a higher level of
abstraction than particle physics
yes and that's why i'm what would be
called a naturalist
and it's why someone like peter singer
is a non-naturalist
he thinks the epistemology of moral
judgments is
a priori and similarly with derek parfit
and they think it's an intuitive
epistemology and they think that the two
go together
because they believe in something called
rational intuition and i'm inclined to
think of intuition the way we were
describing it earlier on
namely it's a complex body of knowledge
that isn't organized into
simple principles but that replicates an
important set of
morally relevant relations and that
that's really what intuition is that
when we have these intuitions it's that
kind of knowledge the way their
grammatical intuitions are
knowledge like that so we disagree about
the epistemology
but parfait at least and i'm not sure
what peter singer would say
our disagreement's not metaphysical
right i think the only place it seems
like there would be space for a
metaphysical disagreement would be
in there being a kind of intrinsic good
quality to pleasure and intrinsic bad
quality
to suffering that existed prior to
conceptualization
well i don't think anything about the
badness of pain depends on our concepts
i think that pain was bad in the first
organisms that felt pain
and if humans had never evolved and the
concept of pain had never come into
existence or the concept of bad and
never come to existence those it'd still
be bad for these organisms to have
suffered
roasting to death in a world that
desiccated or something like that
our concepts allow us to talk about
these features
the word concept comes from two words
khan meaning with
and kep which is a term for grasp and a
concept is what we use to grasp
features of the universe not to create
them so there already would have been
some
computational structure that would have
evaluated something as bad
it would have made it the case that this
was bad for that organism yes that's
right
and that doesn't bring consciousness
into it or anything that could be
strictly computational
thus far yeah and there's a big debate
about whether
states have to be conscious in order for
them to have this value
and one of the reasons for thinking
about that
is because we're thinking about the
animal kingdom and we aren't sure
how deep into the animal ancestry of
humans consciousness goes
i myself don't think that consciousness
is essential
but i recognize that that's one position
among many yeah i happen to
think that it is but i would like now to
wrap up and integrate this
discussion on meta-ethical epistemology
into the broader conversation
so we've talked to hear a lot about what
your meta ethics is
and the epistemology that is entailed by
it and also that of other people's
that is related to moral learning of
course because a proper
moral epistemology is the vehicle by
which one would obtain
normative or meta-ethical moral
knowledge
so how do you view or integrate
this thinking that we've gone through
here
to the question of ai alignment
on one hand if we're singer or parfait
we might think if we just build
something that's sufficiently rational
whatever that means
that axioms of morality would be
intuitively accessible to
such a machine system seems strange to
say
but they would be intuitively accessible
as well as axioms of mathematics
whereas with your view i'm not quite
sure what happened so maybe you could
explore this all a little bit for us so
if i could have my wish here
it would be that by getting an
understanding of the meta-ethical
landscape
and which problems are metaphysical
which ones aren't
which problems are epistemic and how
they are tractable in various ways
the temptation towards skepticism and
morality
would at least be a bit weakened people
would
see how it would be possible for us to
have moral knowledge
of course imperfect and evolving
they would understand therefore how it
could be possible
for other systems to have moral
knowledge
and we could talk concretely about the
kinds of processes
by which infants for example acquire
moral knowledge
and think about how systems could go
through similar kinds of processes and
acquire
a core moral competency as i think they
can
skepticism about morality i think has
for a long time plagued
the discipline because it's been hard
for people to see
how we could have something like moral
knowledge and that's been tied up with a
picture of value in the nature of value
as a unusual kind of something or other
as something that's not part of the way
in which the
world is put together and so how would
we ever have any kind of knowledge of it
and since we can't derive it from
self-evident axioms we have to be
subjectivists
that i would hope to have had just a
small effect in making that
a somewhat less plausible position
because i do think there's a
important constructive project here and
it's already underway in developmental
psychology and for example people
working around josh tenemont
are working on this as a learning
question there's a lot of promise to
understanding intuition in terms of deep
learning and understanding moral
competency in
bayesian terms so i think there's a
tremendous future
for coming to have theories of moral
learning i'm glad psychologists have
started using this phrase
and that by giving a theory of it that
sorts out
the meta-ethical landscape in the ways
we've been describing
that seems more plausible right so in
summary then the feeling that you have
here is that
people hold and walk around with common
sense intuitions about
normative and meta-ethical thinking and
what those things are
and that there is a more solid
foundation for
whatever moral realism might be in
understanding around these issues and
that there can be strong convergence and
formalization
around moral learning and then the
integration of moral learning
to machine systems which would make them
sensitive to morally relevant features
and thus make them socially societally
civilizationally competent to be able to
exist in an ecosystem of agents with
more or less altruistic malevolent and
benevolent
values and that we will need such
systems badly
as allies in the years to come if i
could just add one
thought someone's going to say but don't
we have to have some priors
about pain being bad about positive
some interactions being good then we
have to have some priors
in order to engage in moral learning and
i would say we have to have priors to
engage in
any kind of learning and what
rationality and learning consist in
is how do we use subsequent experience
and evidence and argument
to revise the priors and go on to create
new priors and then apply evidence and
argument
and reasoning to those that's what
rationality is it's not starting from
scratch
with self-evident principles that we
just don't happen to know
that's what bayesians say rationality is
with response to science and the
gathering of evidence
that's a picture of rationality in which
we can be rational beings
and we can be more rational the more we
are able to subject our priors
to critical scrutiny and expose them to
different kinds of more diverse
representative forms of evidence
and reasoning and i think the same thing
is true with moral priors
and rationality in the moral case
doesn't consist in
seeing it as a self-evident set of
axioms because i don't think one can
but starting with priors and then
learning from experience
argument and deliberation together in
that sense rationality
in the two spheres is essentially very
similar
all right peter thanks so much for your
perspective here in sharing all of this
is there anything else here any last
thoughts you'd like to say anything you
feel
unresolved about i would like to have
more
engagement between philosophers and the
ai alignment
community i think it's one of the most
important problems we face
as a culture and it's an urgent problem
and
it's painful to me that philosophers are
not as alive to it as they should be
i just want to invite anyone who's out
there working on the problem
please let's try to make contact not
necessarily with me
but with other philosophers and let's
try to build a constructive community
here
because for too long philosophy has been
in the situation
of folding its arms and sort of
poo-pooing
artificial intelligence or artificial
ethics and
if that view has merit and it does have
merit in many areas
ai gets over hyped a lot the ai people
will tell you that
but there's this other side which is
what has been accomplished what has been
constructed what's been shown to be
possible and how can we build on that
and there i think there's a lot of
opportunity for
constructive interaction so that would
be my parting thought
that this is a time when urgent
work in this area is needed let's bring
all the resources we can to bear on it
all right beautiful thoughts to end on
then if people want to
follow you on social media or get in
contact with you how's the best way to
do that
well i'm not on social media the best
way would be to reach me via email
which is p-r-a-i-l-t-o-n
umich.edu i get a lot of email i can't
promise i'll respond quickly
to emails i wish i could but i don't
want philosophy to lose the chance to be
part of this important process
all right and if people want to check
out your papers or work
i'm supposed to be building a website i
may succeed in doing so
many of the papers are available people
have put them up in various ways so if
you go to google scholar you can find
many of my papers
and i also want to put in a plug for
those philosophers who have heroically
been working
on these questions they've done a great
deal of work
and we should be grateful for what
they've accomplished but yes if people
want to find my work
if they can't get access to it let me
know and i'll
make the papers available all right
thanks again peter it's been really
informative and i appreciate you coming
on
great i appreciate your questions and
your patience this has been very helpful
conversation for me as well
if you enjoyed this podcast please
subscribe give it a like
or share it on your preferred social
media platform we'll be back again soon
with another episode in the ai alignment
[Music]
[Applause]
series
you